earlier on the show we heard how college
leaders are calling on the government to
make lessons on global warming
compulsory they say the uk is unlikely
to reach its net zero target without
change so how do we put climate change
into the curriculum
vicky to you first of all then and just
to give you a statistic less than one
percent of students are on a course with
broad coverage of climate education you
can see that fact there so how important
do you think it is to have climate
change in education for those over 16.
i think it's very important but of
course there are two aspects of climate
change education one is to make people
aware of what the issues are so they
behave in a different way themselves to
the future more responsibly the other
one is to upgrade their skills or make
sure that the skills in the curriculum
that exists uh are fit for whatever it
is that we want to do in the future the
green jobs that are being announced for
example with the net zero strategy an
extra 450 000 supposedly which has been
a figure that we've been talking about
for the past 15 years in my memory um so
it is really whether we're talking about
upskilling and if we know really what
those skills are likely to be needed and
which they are going to be needed in the
future that we not quite sure at present
given that technology is still
unclear and uh there could be all sorts
of areas of activity that will be taking
place in the future that we can't even
imagine right now so the question is
what do we upscale our people for and
are we basically talking about
everything being done in a green way in
other words uh having a lot less
admission for every
ounce of
production that we have in the future
rather than the way we do things at
present so
a bit of an unknown there if you're
going to be teaching it what exactly are
you going to be telling your students
bob do you think that's a fair point
yes but it's important to remember that
students before 16 already
are taught about climate change as part
of the national curriculum both in
science and in geography so beyond 16
it's a conversation about what how to
put it in not just in science and in
environment but also in in other
subjects such as economics and law and i
know that students at lse for instance
london school of economics where i am
really do want to learn more about
climate change and the way it's
affecting all aspects of our lives and
our economy well that's so interesting
isn't it vicky and some people might say
this this idea is pushing at an open
door i mean we've seen all the school
strikes a lot of those children actually
younger than 16 but there is an
enthusiasm you might say amongst younger
people that it's perhaps not there in
some of the older generations
well the interesting thing is that when
you do surveys about climate change and
awareness and whether you want to do
something about it we find that all
generations in the uk certainly seem to
be quite committed to it and understand
the issues so it's not just confined to
any particular age group but what
worries me is that there has been this
huge cut in funding for further
education in other words
reskilling the older population those
who may need to change their jobs or the
way they do their jobs and that funding
needs to be restored if we are at all
serious about ensuring that population
we have at prison who is in the labor
force uh and always about to get into
the labor force is able to deal with
things for the future